I don't like to play favorites but
breakfast is definitely my favorite meal
of the day if I have like too light of a
breakfast or a breakfast that just like
doesn't hit I feel it all day long it
totally sets the tone for the day I know
a lot of you guys are students and
heading back to school or your parents
and you're sending your little ones back
to class and with the rising food cost
right now I know that pretty much
everyone is on a budget
[Music]
so I've got five budget-friendly
breakfast recipes that don't require
buying an avocado for three bucks and a
lot of them contain the same ingredients
so you can stretch your budget and
switch it up for variety and I'll pop up
on screen what each cost per serving so
you can find the best recipe that works
for you alright let's cook but first let
me tell you about my sponsor clean my
Mac as a dietitian I spent a lot of my
time learning about ways to optimize my
own health and well well-being why not
do the same for my Mac baby Honestly
though my whole life literally exists on
my computer so I will do anything to
keep my Mac safe and healthy so clean my
Mac X is a software that helps clean and
optimize your Mac by deleting junk
malware and unused apps and makes your
computer faster safer and more organized
millions of users around the world have
been using this award-winning service
for the past 14 years and it's well
regarded by Apple themselves my favorite
feature is the Smart scan that examines
the system for log files and years of
cache that I don't need anymore and
helps me make more room for all of the
great photos and video content that I
make for you I also keep tabs on my
battery life and how long it takes to
fully charge which can help me plan for
days that I'm working away from home
they also a space lens which allows you
to easily see which files are taking up
the most space malware removal to scan
for viruses and remove them instantly
and the menu app helps to increase the
long of your Mac so if you're a Mac User
and you want to get the most out of your
investment check out my link in the
description to learn more first
breakfast is for the meal prepper if I
can find a way to cook breakfast like
once and then eat it all week long or
even into the next few weeks I am down
and I love this recipe because you
actually can freeze it so it will last
even longer than a meal prep that has to
stay in the fridge so we're gonna make
some quick little freezer oatmeal cups
all right whoa
it's not an exact science here folks
we're just gonna
estimate a couple cups I'm gonna do like
two and a half of the oats I've got some
flax which of course you guys know I
love all my little sprinkles this is a
great addition of fiber Protein healthy
fats
built-in hunger crushing combo
two about a half cup of that
all right let's get all our dries in
cinnamon lots of cinnamon and you cannot
cook oatmeal without a solid pinch of
salt
oatmeal without salt is Nast just saying
so we're gonna do
half water
oh that's gonna make a
hand like half some kind of milk we're
gonna make this completely plant-based
um so I'm using this kind of almond
cashew protein milk but you can use
whatever kind of milk you guys drink
whatever you've got on hand totally
works
all right
spark up
okay so as that is just thickening I
like to add a little natural sweetness
from a banana banana
so that's what I'm gonna do this is
totally optional I know there's a lot of
banana phobes out there so you can just
omit this if you want and just like add
more maple syrup or honey whatever is
your jam oh
oh run away the people who are upset
about bananas probably really upset that
I just licked banana
skin off me now I do like a lot of
peanut butter that's mainly the oil
just get a good glob in there
that's going to add some healthy fats
more fiber
more protein
we love to see it
give that a good stir and mash that
banana down
just give it a good Tamp
is a great word
not sure it makes sense in this but it's
gonna be my word of the day word of the
day Tamp
not tampon
a tan
you gotta say it like that
more peanut butter
so always
room from our peanut butter
okay
see now she's thick
all right are you a brown sugar maple
syrup
honey
or other
sweetener in your oatmeal brown sugar
brown sugar I know it is the class
ick
classic
I'm in a short form mood
um I don't know where my brown sugar is
so I'm gonna grab some maple
my kids usually request Maple Syrup and
Honey but we can always do that when I
serve it so that's probably good
always room for more to be served
it looks good to me oatmeal porn
I could just eat this right out of the
pot but
we are committed to the meal prep
so we prep
so I got some little silicone molds here
and
I'm just gonna set them out there's a
lot of reasons why I like this method I
mean yes I could make oatmeal in the
morning but it does take time to make it
from rolled oats in a pot and it makes a
mess every single morning I'd rather
make a mess one morning and then just
kind of Pop these in the microwave to
warm them up or if you love like an
overnight oat situation you can just
take one or two of these with you right
from the freezer to work with you and by
the time you get to work and you want to
eat your breakfast it'll thaw out and
it's kind of like a cold overnight oat
situation
so you can just leave them as this and
then add some fruit later or you can add
some like blooms you could do a little
these are local
um
strawberries that we just picked so they
basically cost me nothing
and they're so good I'm gonna throw a
few in there
and then
my kids would be
quite upset
if I didn't do some chocolate chip ones
for them
all right
I'm gonna put this in the freezer so
once they're frozen solid you can pop
them into a resealable bag or resealable
container just to save some space in the
freezer and when you're ready to eat
just pop them out I'm going to take two
put them into my bowl maybe one
blueberry one strawberry I'm Gonna Save
the chocolate chips for the kiddos
I feel like I need a couple more because
your girl is hungry
all right now let's try it
there you go all right a little milk on
top
maybe a few extra
Lubes for good measure
and a little Canada's finest
nice
hmm
that is perfection normal microwave oats
just cannot compete with this
all right next breakfast is for the
snacker so I feel like Starbucks is
charging like eight bucks for a couple
hard-boiled eggs that have probably been
sitting in the fridge for a while and
some really flaccid cheese and soft
grapes there's nothing worse than
[ __ ] soft grapes argue with me in the
comments eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs eggs
eggs eggs eggs eggs
let's do
like six
two
knowing me I'd like
crack the egg as we put them in
all right six eggs
that wasn't that's not an inch
yeah the eggs
yeah okay good enough
okay now we wait
so much we have to wait for
10 minutes on the clock and it's later
let's go drain these bad boys
all right we got our Bento Box we're
gonna pack our little snack or breakfast
here any kind of fruit peaches are in
season they are super inexpensive right
now where I live so we're getting a
peach it's very fuzzy though we gotta
wash that
this guy needs like a thorough wax job
uh Kelly Clarkson all right we got some
cheese let's throw him in here some nuts
you're gonna love my nuts some whole
grain crackers I love Triscuits they're
so delicious
and let's peel our eggs
Perfecto Ellen
so you got to look for that Arrow air
pocket so that you can get the shells
off without just mangling the whole
thing let's get a little salt in there
mmm
perfection
you ready for this Brody
so ready
I might hit you
I know you're supposed to do this
and you're supposed to throw these two
at the same time
what do you mean two oh okay fine
yeah I can do that no I can't even do
that
oh God
I'm gonna end up with peach juice all
over me
hey I need
to
watch
[Music]
how crazy do my eyes look right now
because I feel crazy
that's what you're gonna get
we'll call this breakfast the early bird
so if you don't mind cleaning a pan
before 9am this is the breakfast for you
so we're going to be making some little
egg wraps these are super versatile you
can literally add in whatever kind of
veggies and things that you like and you
can also make these plant-based with
like a plant-based alternative or tofu
but of course that will change the cost
let's do it
a little bit of oil I like to do a
little bit of butter with the oil just
adds a lot of great flavor
and I'm going to pre-scramble my eggs
oh
is interrupting my photo shoot
what goodies do we have what's your
alarm
all right
there's lots going on here
getting stressful
I'm going to add some cheese
lots of it
and
I've got some frozen chopped spinach so
as I discussed in my grocery shop video
where I was grocery shopping on a budget
frozen spinach is such a cheap and
cheerful way to get in your veg so
always have them on hand for kind of
breakfast like this
let it cook down
a little salt
all right let's let that sit for a sucky
nice color
maybe more cheese
it can never go wrong with cheese
you don't like cheese you don't have to
add cheese but I like cheese
this is looking good
get those guys in there
and I got some really delicious hot
sauce here you can obviously use ketchup
any kind of sauce no sauce you do you
they're your damn egg tacos so
a little bit
a little bit a little bit of Monica
by my side
and because I feel like some fruit in
the Sun cause I like a little sweet
saver combination we picked these
apricots from our friend's house
they're super small and they look like
they have monkey pox but they are damn
Delicious and they were free so I'm
gonna add that on the side
this is an over the sink operation
um
the cheese the hot sauce the spinach the
eggs
the whole thing is a masterpiece
now we'll do what we'll call The Lazy
breakfast though I prefer like we'll go
with the busy breakfast because let's be
real most days I don't feel like I'm
lazy I just don't have the time to do
much else and I still need to feed
myself so we're gonna do my famous
little hack my protein cereal with some
simple peanut butter toast great thing
about this recipe is you can use
whatever cereal you like the sugary
cereal is great because we're gonna add
lots of protein and some healthy fats
and it's gonna be delicious and well
balanced so if you like your Lucky
Charms this is a great way to eat them
so I've got some protein powder any
protein powder will do flavored
unflavored you do you you choose your
own protein cereal magical Adventure so
that's going in then we're going to add
whatever milk you normally eat your
cereal with it's like we're low
and you want to like get it to a texture
that isn't like clumpy and thick because
we're also going to add in our cereal
so just takes a little bit of whisking
here does this count as putting cereals
after the milk though well like I know
that's controversial yeah this is a this
is a sticking point for a lot of people
do you put the cereal in after the milk
do you put the milk in after the cereal
in this case you kind of have to do the
milk first because you have to you want
to get the protein powder dissolved in
the milk before you add the cereal it's
fine if you don't but then you're gonna
possibly get clumps of protein powder on
your cereal and it's not as not as
appetizing all right this is feeling
good to me I love puffins if you guys
watch my content you know I love puffins
it's probably one of our favorite
cereals around here and it's high in
fiber so we love to see it kids love it
that looks good
and it might be a little more and I just
thought out some frozen black cherries
frozen fruit is a great cost effective
way to get your produce in especially
when things aren't like super in season
or they're more expensive when they're
fresh and cherries are always pretty
expensive here in Canada
so I'm going to add some of those on top
[Music]
cherry juice
oh it's just
delicious all right step one
let's make some toast look at this
sourdough bread obviously use whatever
bread you have sandwich bread baked
bread homemade bread Lord knows I don't
have time for that especially sourdough
we all went through that phase of
beginner pandemic and I have PTSD about
nursing the starter so bottle loaf of
bread we're gonna slather it in some nut
butter
it's a great way to get some healthy
fats in this meal oh yeah baby
foreign
optional but you know I love it
and also optional
a little honey
hello baby all right
let's eat
so that took a whole two minutes to make
[Music]
the cherries
they just had different
and finally for the family fave we're
gonna do one of my family's favorite
breakfasts sheet pan pancakes are you
saying pan or Pam this recipe is ideal
if you've got like a little bit more
time on the weekend or on a particular
morning because of course it does need
to be cooked but it's way less time
consuming than having to make pancakes
the traditional way by like flipping it
on the stovetop because you just make it
in a sheet pan you cut it up and you
don't have to babysit it so let's do it
we're going to start with some whole
wheat flour you can use oat flour or
gluten-free flour this is just a really
inexpensive way to get a little bit more
fiber in
got some flax
[Applause]
a little bit of baking powder
that's probably good uh again loads of
cinnamon or any other baking spice that
you love salt
so we need a cup and a half of
cottage cheese
I love cottage cheese I think it's so
underrated and forgotten about I love
the flavor I love the texture and if you
don't like the texture it doesn't matter
because you're not going to even taste
it it's just going to add a ton of
protein
so let's just
try to do a decent job at
measuring
good enough
this recipe is very forgiving as are all
of my recipes
because usually I just
make them on the Fly and I never bust
out
any kind of measuring utensils all right
vanilla
definitely not measuring and eggs
to buckle my shoe oh my God just stuck
my finger in here did that was that
already broken
so questionable but I'm not gonna risk
it
two
three
four
okay I need bananas after I wash my
hands wash your hands the bananas again
are just for adding body and also adding
natural sweetness if you don't like them
I'm not sure what to substitute with
maybe some ripe mango I feel like that
would do the trick as well
okay all right it's puree
don't include this
all right
you get your sheet pan
you just give it a good spray or
some that's probably fine don't want to
stick
and we
I need some kind of a spatula situation
I'm already making such a damn mess I
don't want to waste any of it it'll do
and we scrape the bottom of this
get out your handy dandy spatula
and get her done
now just
smoother out
so satisfying it's like icing a cake
try to get it nice and even now you can
just leave this naked as is and then
decorate it once it's baked or you can
throw some berries in if you'd like
which is what I'm going to do I've got
some more bloops
just a few
throw a little extra flavor and
sweetness
I always get like try to be just random
about this stuff but I get really like
obsessed with being like holding on a
blue over here not enough red over here
ah I got half a banana here because my
kids didn't finish it so I'm going to
just use that up too
there's always like half eaten pieces of
fruit all over my house so it's a great
way to use it up okay so for my friends
who also struggle with
ocd-like tendencies
how
frustrated are you right now with
my distribution
of fruit
I think we have to just cover it in some
hemp hearts and call it a damn day hemp
hearts just
Mellow Me Out
just make it all a little bit better
Just a Touch
all right and that's an optional
addition you don't need to add it in I
just love the little extra nuttiness and
crunch and of course all the fiber
protein and healthy fats it adds let's
put this in the oven all right looks
like Perfection let's let her cool and
then we'll cut it up
how big do we want to go let's go big or
go home friends
let's do some monster slices
that's too monster
not just
do a little slicey slice
just like that
nice corner piece
oops
um
I like to serve mine with little greek
yogurt on top
and a little bit of peanut butter too
well that was what it was
and some extra berries
and obviously
I'd like music just like oh yeah
laughs
this is my favorite mm-hmm
[Music]
so we're gonna be excited to come home
to this a little local straw
[Music]
there you have it five easy back to
school breakfast ideas that you can make
at home on a budget if you guys like
this video and you want to see more
recipe content from me please leave me a
comment below on what you'd like to see
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye foreign
[Music]